it is a strong liquor with an historic
pass today we're celebrating National
moonshine day what's the better way to
celebrate moonshine day than with some
moonshine joining us this morning
mixologists Marissa and Dane pretkus
with City Light Shine we're talking
about the history of moonshine cocktails
and your involvement in downtown Las
Vegas guys thanks for coming in this
morning we appreciate it thanks for
having me thanks for having us so you
guys have a lot
of a box yeah we do we own a bar
downtown it's called horse trailer
Hideout awesome
um we are two years we just celebrated
our two year anniversary in April
congratulations thank you so much and
one of the drinks that you sling at the
bar is a little moonshine this has
actually been on our Shelf since the day
one we've opened awesome yeah we love to
support local Spirits um City Light
Shine has been around since 2016.
Brennan gone actually is the originator
of this product and he works with a
distiller Mike Dolan but they make some
pretty fantastic spirits well let's talk
about what moonshine is I think when we
think about moonshine in my head I'm
thinking okay it's like prohibition
prohibition there's like super strong
bathtubs in the basement people are
making it illegally but what is
moonshine so a lot of people refer to it
as like a white whiskey moonshine is
traditionally a corn mash but it
actually is known for its distilling
process that's why it's become so
dangerous the Menthol and it is not
exactly the best to consume okay so it's
strong but also could be tough to tough
to make safety yeah well homebrews you
know no no you don't want to do that
leave it to the professionals yeah right
but you guys have flavors I mean City
Lights has what is this blueberry
lemonade strawberry lemonade yeah
blueberry a Cherry Lemon and they have a
strawberry they also have a candy bar
and key lime we were using the key lime
today and they have original but my
personal favorite is The Salted Caramel
oh yes please yeah your bar is in the
arts district right next to Able Baker
right on Main Street right what are
folks that look at people are at home
they want to maybe celebrate National
moonshine day what do you guys have on
tap so what we're making today is we're
making two traditional kind of well our
take on some moonshine cocktails oh I
love this yeah this is how you start a
Thursday by the way
able to find these we're serving them
all day today for National moonshine day
at our bar today and then if you miss
them we're going to continue them on to
first Friday tomorrow even better and
that's tahin I'm guessing around the rim
there yeah for a little spice
I love it yeah this is going to be our
Clementine oh so we're using some
Original Moonshine we're using orange
juice grapefruit some local desert agave
nectar okay and then he used some fresh
orange in there with a tequila oh look
at that now you can drink the Moonshine
straight all right this one is um this
one is actually 40 it's an 80 proof yeah
okay oh that's all you Heather that's
all you right there can I try it
absolutely
I don't even need to ask oh man all
right there we go natural moonshine day
is today we're talking with the city
lights shine and the name of the box
please
trailer hideout in the Art District
thanks guys for coming we appreciate it
Hey sir smells fantastic